NAZMUL IDRIS: Welcome
to this episode of UXD
where we will highlight
one of three common missed
opportunities for apps to
deliver delight to their users.
It's the second episode in the
Three Steps to Awesome series.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris, a developer
advocate passionate
about designing mobile.
And I have with me
a very special guest
on the show today.
PATRICK LARVIE:
Hey, thanks, Nazmul.
I'm Patrick Larvie.
I'm a researcher here at Google.
I've been focusing
on user experience
and mobile for a long time.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Awesome.
So apps that are widely
divergent from platform
guidelines are usually
not a good idea.
You should try and make
people feel at home
in your application by
following platform guidelines
wherever you can,
and be consistent
so that the user's
expectations from that platform
are met from inside
of that application.
So, for example, an
Android user expects
that your Android version
of your application
feels at home on Android.
And similarly, an iOS
user has an expectation
that the iOS version
of your application
should feel at home on iOS.
Keep in mind, it's their phone.
Users identify very deeply
with a particular phone,
and they think about
it as their phone.
They don't say that this
is my Android or iOS.
They think of it as my phone.
And so your application has to
make sure that it fits inside
of whatever idea they have
of their particular phone,
and not get hung up on these
technical details around which
platform the application
is running on.
Because, again, the
user doesn't care.
PATRICK LARVIE:
That's right, Nazmul.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So
there are reasons
for deviating from
these guidelines,
but you must have a good
reason to deviate from them.
Deviating without a
particularly good reason
is generally not a good idea.
PATRICK LARVIE:
That's exactly right.
When people talk
about their phones,
they don't talk about my
Apple 5 point whatever.
They say this is my iPhone.
And I think the idea of
making people feel at home
begins with the
kind of nomenclature
we use when we develop apps.
So, for example, what's
the opposite of short?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Tall.
PATRICK LARVIE:
Not at Starbucks.
NAZMUL IDRIS: What?
PATRICK LARVIE: At Starbucks,
the opposite of short
is trenta.
Another example for
Android is making
sure the buttons do what
people expect them to do.
A Back button should take you--
NAZMUL IDRIS: Back.
PATRICK LARVIE: Not necessarily.
I've seen Back
buttons do all kinds
of funny unexpected things.
It can make you add the
app, it can take you back
to the home screen, it
can do all kinds of things
that people don't
necessarily expect.
So it's important to remember
that design guidelines are not
there just because
people like guidelines,
they're there
because we want users
to feel at home on
their phones no matter
what app they're using.
You can deviate with
purpose, and there's
some really good
examples of this.
For instance, in the latest
version of the YouTube app,
you'll notice that
the YouTube app has
gone to a card-based
design, so you
can scroll through
all kinds of content.
And when you find something
you like, you click on it
and the content can
actually pop out
and you can watch the video
in a much smaller square
that you can move
around your screen.
Why did they do this?
This is actually quite unusual.
It's a very
purposeful deviation.
The reason they did this
is so that you can continue
to watch that video as you
scroll through the content
and find something
else to watch.
There are lots of instances
where people say things
like I really want my app
to reflect the quirkiness
or the specificity of my brand.
This is generally a bad idea.
The way to express your brand
is by having an awesome design
that fits the guidelines
of the platform
and makes your user feel
completely in charge.
As an example, I hope
that everyone watching
goes and checks
out the Airbnb app.
It's amazing.
It will replace the
desktop entirely for you,
and you will be
awed and inspired
by how they've taken-- they've
designed within the guidelines
to come up with an app that's
very, very unique to Airbnb
and is, in my opinion,
one of the best
apps I've seen in a long time.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
I think the key here is
respecting a user's choice,
whether it's the choice
of the device they've
made or the platform,
even the social network
that they're using, for
example, for social sign in.
I think the most
important thing is
that, as a developer,
when you're
building an application
that's going
to live in a
particular platform,
make sure that your
application does not
feel like a second
class citizen.
Because the user
be able to know.
The user is savvy.
They have really, really
high expectations,
and so it's really,
really important
to make sure that you
respect their choice,
and also make sure that
your applications are giving
a first class experience for
their particular platform
on their particular device.
PATRICK LARVIE: For
example, Nazmul,
if I invite you over
to my house and I say,
hey, I've got this
great bottle of wine,
would you like to
share it with me?
And you say to me, hey, that's
awesome, where's a straw?
Give me a straw.
That's terrible.
Why is that terrible?
Because the entire point of
inviting him over to share
this bottle of
wine is that we're
going to drink it together.
This is the point of
playing well with others.
Think of a mobile phone
exactly the same way.
Your app is playing
on that phone
with lots of others
at the same time.
You need to remember that.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
And the key is that, just
like the bottle of wine,
they are resources
on your phone that
are very limited,
like CPU, network,
and memory, and each application
instead of essentially sticking
in a straw and consuming all
of CPU network and memory,
it should really be in a
more sharing state of mind.
And so a good way to do this
is to keep efficiency in mind.
So one of the biggest things
you could do as a developer
is make sure that
your applications are
aware of battery consumption,
network consumption,
and display constraints.
We talked about the Caturday
app in part one of this series,
and it was a Caturday app that
allows you to get documentaries
on cats on your mobile device.
So one of things you can do is
that if the application detects
that you're going low on
battery, maybe instead
of allowing you to play
a particular video,
it would allow you to queue it.
Similarly, if you're
not low on battery,
but it senses that you're on
a device that has a very, very
small screen or a really
low resolution display,
instead of giving you
the HD quality video that
would consume a lot more
battery and network,
instead it should give you
a lower resolution video
that you can't even
tell the difference when
you're using this application.
So similarly, another
thing to keep in mind,
and this is really
to data transfers,
is to try and use the big cookie
model for transferring data.
Big cookie model
just means instead
of doing really
small data transfers
intermittently, you bash them
together and do one big one.
And there's a reason for this.
The cellular radio
on your phone,
it actually drains
battery at a rapid rate
when you power the radio
from idle to high power mode.
And so if you can limit
how often you do this,
that will actually end
up giving your users
savings on their battery.
And in line with that, you
should also think before you
sync, which is kind of
tied to the same concept
where instead of kicking
off your own syncing
operations using your own
timer, you should try and bash
this with system syncs.
What will happen is that the
system will wake up the radio,
take the hit for going from
idle to high power mode,
and then while it's powered
up, all the applications
that need data synced, it can
do all of that at the same time.
Again, giving you more
savings on battery.
And finally, when you're
testing and building
these applications make sure
to use an old device that
is resource constrained.
Because if you're testing on
the latest and greatest Nexus
with multiple cores and
many, many gigabytes of RAM,
you might get away with things
that you won't on an older
device, and that's a really
good practice to get into.
PATRICK LARVIE:
This also applies
to your choice of technologies.
So as your user is going
along and using our app,
and let's say, we'll go
back to the cat video app,
it's time to watch a
cat video, and suddenly
you find that the technology
requirements for watching
that cat video are inconsistent
with your platform.
So how many times, and I'm
thinking very specifically
about Flash, think about
those iOS users out there.
That know this is a
planned incompatibility,
and Nazmul's point is that
you should plan for delight.
That's absolutely true.
You should also bear in mind
that not everyone shares
the same technology stack.
There are other ways
of thinking of that.
So if you can use
HTML5, for example,
that might be a better choice.
NAZMUL IDRIS: No, exactly.
In this particular
case, let's say
you do have a valid reason to
use Flash for a device where
it's not going to run, you
should consider failing very
gracefully instead of
just giving a 404 message,
or plug-in not
found, or something
that a user can't
really understand.
So one of the things
to keep in mind
is when you're choosing a
technology stack, consider
using your familiarity
as a developer.
With that stack,
keep the user in mind
when deciding
which stack to use.
Because, again, you're
building the application
to live on your user's
device, which is their device.
So another related to this
selection of technology
stack is determining which
version of a platform
to use, like what APIs to use.
So, for example,
on end rate, you
might think that based on
market share statistics
and so on, that if you want
to deliver an application that
reaches the largest
number of users, then
you're going to target
a lower version API.
So that's not
entirely the truth,
because market stats
don't show you everything.
While that might be true,
if you provide a lowest
common denominator
experience, then arguably,
the users of your application
won't be that delighted.
So what we're saying is
that you can deliver delight
while taking these
constraints into account.
So for example, if you take
KitKat features into account,
that is, build that
into your application,
so that KitKat users
of your application
can experience all
the KitKatness,
but at the same time,
Gingerbread users
can also experience sort
of the baseline capability
of your application.
That way you're
delighting folks that
have higher versions of
Android on their phone,
for example, while not really
taking anything away from,
let's say, the folks
that are on Gingerbread.
PATRICK LARVIE: The signature
of a really, really awesome app
isn't the fact that
problems never occur,
it's the fact that
the app handles
those problems very,
very elegantly.
So before you release
that app, imagine that,
no matter how awesome it is,
and I'm sure it's awesome,
you are going to have
all kinds of problems.
You're going to have
error messaging.
networks that go out.
You're going to have
batteries that run out.
You're going to have people like
me with big fat fingers that
aren't very accurate
on touch screens.
You're going to
have bad lighting.
You know those awesome
graphics that you have,
people may not see them in
all lighting conditions.
Plan for these things.
Again, the signature
of an awesome app
isn't that problems don't occur,
is that a fantastic app will
handle these problems
very elegantly.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
I think on mobile, one of
the most important things
to keep in mind is that
network coverage is spotty
and bandwidth varies
quite greatly,
and so one of the
key things to nail
in a good mobile experience
is to get offline mode right.
Because if you don't take that
into account, a lot of times
you might have a UX
fail, where somebody
goes to use your
application and you
know it was working great
with perfect network coverage,
but they're in a
particular part of town
where your carrier doesn't
have that great of a coverage
and there's no Wi-Fi.
And guess what?
Your application
just stops working.
And that just leaves a
bad taste in their mouth.
So Gmail is a really good
example of offline mode,
where Gmail just hides the fact
that you have or don't have
network conductivity and
allows you to compose emails,
it allows you to
manage your inbox
and so on, and then as soon
as you get connectivity,
it just goes ahead and syncs
everything with your Gmail.
So one nice thing is when
you're creating meaningful error
messages, I think it's
really important to also
give the user a
path to resolution,
so that they can
recover from this error
rather than just notify
them that something bad has
happened.
So I hope you
enjoyed our episode.
Stay tuned for the final episode
in this three part series,
which is coming soon.
Just remember, by following
these three steps,
you too can avoid
common pitfalls
and make applications awesome.
And also, if you
haven't already,
please join our UX community
on Google+ where we curate
information about all
things related to UX.
Thank you, Patrick,
for being on the show.
PATRICK LARVIE: Thank you very
much, Nazmul, for having me.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Thanks for
watching and join us next time.
Good bye.
PATRICK LARVIE: Bye-bye.